i just finished my round one game uh
about 20 minutes ago
and here i am doing the recap
um
before i get into the game i will say
i'm really tired so i might keep this a
bit more brief than usual
but it was a really crazy game and i
think there's uh
there's a lot of
things to learn from this game
and i'm still trying to
wrap my mind around what happened
so let's get into it um i played gm
alexander predki who's the third seed in
the tournament almost a super gm
feeder rating of 2692
and if you saw the previous video you
know that my game plan was to play
london
and uh before the game um i did some
more general london preparation
i was expecting him to
try and surprise me in some way and
he played a line that i actually didn't
look at
uh before the game which is c5 and queen
music
and this is a line that actually again
matar
has like a popular video on the
so-called anti-london
um but this is a line that i've played
many times before and i'm prepared for
played the move knight a3 uh with idea
that if queen digs b2 i can play knight
b5
and uh i think there's lines where white
can even like force a draw
which maybe
uh would be nice against a player rated
several hundred points higher than me
um another idea of the knight a3 is that
if black plays a6
preventing knight b5 then i have knight
c4
which attacks the queen and defends b2
and we got a similar version of this um
in the game he played d6 knight c4 queen
c7
knight f3 g6
and around here i had
some like weird memory pop into my mind
uh from the time that i was teaching
alexandra botez the london
and
i'm gonna have to dig up the video to
see if i had shown her this position but
uh
there's an idea here that i wanted to
play
but i couldn't remember if this was a
position
or not
but the idea is to play a very quick e4
and i'll just toggle engine analysis
uh to show
um
and it looks actually to be playable and
the point is after takes queen e2
uh there's alignment on e-file and if
the knight moves and there's knight
takes d6 which is crushing for for white
uh so black would have to play f5 here
and um
i i considered this briefly during the
game but i just didn't have any
preparation in it or any memory of what
i had looked at
but apparently g4 and the position gets
crazy and maybe this is something i can
prepare
for the future if i want to have a
a much sharper position from early on
but instead of going into the craziness
i decided to stay solid
and after g6 just played bishop b2
and next three moves are very standard
uh we both complete development
now b5 and i should note that i could
have played a4
to prevent b5 and maybe i should have
um
but i love b5 with idea that after okay
after
what happened the game um black ends up
playing a6
uh i have the move here a4 um an attempt
to try and undermine the queenside pawns
and i'd be very happy if black takes i
take back and this a pawn is kind of a
long-term weakness on the half-open file
the ideas of queen a1
but in hindsight
after i played a4
um black played b4
and i realized that maybe this wasn't
the best transformation for me
because it's very difficult for me to
play c3 now
and
d4 ends up becoming
somewhat of a liability
even though it's a
defended center pawn
it's just hard to get my pawns in a
harmonious way on the queen side
and my original intention
when i played a4 was to meet b4 with a5
uh to try and artificially isolate this
pawn
but i decided not to go for this because
after knight c6 i thought my apon could
be weak and it's very easy to defend the
b-pawn for black
so instead i went for
a more solid play rookie one and uh
brought my bishop out
and we did some dancing after knight a5
bishop d3 bishop b7 queen e2
e6 i think this was all like very normal
we were just
both kind of gradually improving uh
we're both very solid too
and then after rook fc8
i actually didn't quite know what to do
here
and um i haven't analyzed with the
engine yet so uh
i'm sure
i probably had a better approach to what
i did in the game
what i ended up playing was rook ec1
and uh knight f1
but this felt like somewhat of a waste
of time and black was able to get some
uh some more activity
so i'm real quick to check here
and just see
what the engine wants
engine says it's very close to equal
h4 did not cross my mind
because black has h5
uh but maybe even yeah black has other
alternatives too
um
yeah maybe it's already a little bit
unpleasant for white
so it's just hard to find a move with a
clear plan
um
so let me just show what happened in the
game rookie c1 knight f1
my intention was to maneuver knight to
e3 which
i did
and
i'm offering the trade if knight takes
knight i'd be very happy to take back
with that pawn solidify the
the d-pawn and then probably get the
rook to the half of an f-file
instead my opponent played 97 avoiding
the trade and
i think this turned out to be like a
really annoying move
because
now black has the idea of taking
and then winning the d-pawn and the
d-pawn isn't so easy to defend
i can't play c3 now because knight b3
so i had to resort to
using tactics to defend the pawn
and i play the move rook d1 here
i'm going to disable engine analysis
until i actually need it
so the point of rook d1 was that uh if
black takes and snags the pawn
i think there's a few reasonable moves
for white their beat bishop takes g6 for
one uh winning back the pawn hitting
this and this
and uh yeah this is probably just better
for white
so
uh yeah he didn't take on f3 but instead
played knight f5
and here the position transforms a bit
and i had a decision to make because of
course the d-pawn is now hit twice
i was pretty sure i had to take on f5 i
spent a bit of time
deciding whether to take with the knight
or with the bishop
for a while i was
i i was thinking about just knight takes
but then i realized that after pawn
takes
my bishop is just really restricted
and i just didn't see a clear
follow-up in this position
so i thought
i thought bishop takes uh would just be
an easier position to play for white
because that way the pawn is defended by
the rook
and even though i can see the bishop
pair
it leads to some interesting imbalances
so he takes back with epon
i improved my bishop
rookie 8
and now i play
a very double-edged move
and i played this move knowing
it's probably very risky but i thought
it also offers me
some interesting chances
move is d5
and this is a sacrifice
allowing bishop takes b2
played rook b1 bishop c3
and when i played d5 i saw that this
position was likely to come and i went
through with my original intention as
rook d3
and um
yeah black uh black plays rook c8 and
now rook takes c3
so the whole intention was to sack the
exchange remove black's dark sport
bishop
and get a position where the dark
squares are very weak on the king's side
for lack
unfortunately the
just the concrete lines
i don't know if they work for white um
as we'll see in the game
um because what happened is pawn takes
rook
rook b4
and around here i was beginning to feel
optimistic
thinking that uh okay i have this idea
with potential rook lifts
and i thought these pieces are
very much sidelined
um
but black has a really nice
resource here
uh which i thought was
at first not playable but uh
as we'll see it's uh
it leads to a very interesting line
as bishop takes g5
now of course it's a pin and looks like
black just won a pawn now activating the
bishop
but now i have knight takes d5
and i had seen this coming from a
distance but i guess i i didn't realize
that it could just be losing for white
um as we'll see what happens rook takes
e2
i win back the queen
and i got
two minor pieces for rook now
because
i sacked exchange but then black sacked
a piece
but after roxy two
it's
it's not clear if i can stop the pawn
and
i went into this thinking that okay
there's a lot of chances for camera play
i played the move bishop takes e6
and i was still feeling optimistic
thinking okay bishop e5 is coming i'm
gonna have knight f6
and um
it seems like
black might end up getting in a mating
that
but in this position my opponent played
a really nice prophylactic move which i
just overlooked
is pawn f6
not rushing with moving the rook and
trying to promote the pawn
but rather preventing my
main source of counter play
and after f6 i
i had started getting pretty low on time
i was falling
i think falling below five minutes
and i realized that
i'm in big trouble here given that um
this pawn is very hard to stop and if
um pretty much the only way to stop it
is to sacrifice material which would
likely lead to a losing ending
so i tried to stir up some counter play
here with bishop e7
attacking f6 but i think from here on
out uh my opponent played just very
cleanly starting with rook d2
uh this is another move i overlooked
but very nice move because if i take
takes and now d1 is coming
and if rook b1 there is rook c1
so there's all these promotion tactics
when the pawn is so close to queening
yeah so i took on f6
king g8
and now i sacked on c3
um
i didn't quite see
any of like any reasonable alternative
uh what did i want to play
i wanted to play something like knight
b6
but then the problem is just c2
and
yeah even though both rooks are hanging
the pawn is just gonna queen next move
and i can only take one rook at a time
so
i sack on c3
and at this point i had maybe a minute
left to my opponent's 10 minutes
and uh there was a 30 second increment
so i was able to survive on the
increment for
a bit longer
but at this point i'm down the exchange
and
yeah my opponent played just really
clean chest to simplify
um
it still looks like there's some counter
chances
and maybe if this were like a bullet
game online i would have
some hope
but uh as we'll see after rook c2 and
then rook b2 i'm getting massacred on
the second rank
and um
yeah we got to this position
and
i had some hallucination here uh
originally i was gonna play g4 thinking
oh i'm so clever threatening g5 king h5
rook h7 mate
uh but then i realized oh black just has
made in one
so
i i didn't play g4 and at this point i
realized it's uh just completely lost
i gave um
gave a check got the knight to g5
but it was just a formality at this
point
and
yeah no stalemate tricks even because i
have
passed a pawn
and uh yeah i'm just getting mated very
soon
so i threw in the towel here
and uh and yeah that was game one
um
i don't know
what my losing mistake was
but i think overall it was a very
instructive game and like very well gate
well played game for my opponent
uh i want to go back and just check
to see if i had any chances after i
sacked the exchange
if we go
yeah after rook d3 and rook c8 let's see
was i just much worse
okay rook c3
or b4 yeah bishop d5
yeah during the game it it looked
interesting but uh i guess white white
just doesn't have anything here
and uh if i go back even further
any any alternative
no it just looks like i got outplayed
even after knight f5
okay engine wants knight takes f5
e takes f5 and then bishop f4
but yeah i've always felt like i was
just
a little bit under pressure
and my opponent was just in control the
whole game
um so kudos for my opponent um
and
i guess it's a matter of trying to
rebound or round two um
yeah i'm i'm gonna get some food i'm
kind of hungry and kind of tired too
i'm still trying to overcome jet lag but
i hope people enjoy this game um hope
people enjoy the analysis
i'm probably not going to edit this much
i might just put the whole rough cut
to youtube
especially because there's two games
tomorrow
the next round is at 10 am
uae time and then there's another game
at 6 00 p.m
so
sleep
and food
are my top priorities right now
so i'll see you guys in the future stay
tuned for more chess